let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michael's
podcast and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
good morning to all of you
good morning good morning good morning
[Music]
sorry we're running just a tad bit late
i don't know why but we are
here we are here we are here we are we
are here
at the tony michaels podcast
coming to you every single monday
through friday every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central on youtube twitter
and twitch
and now from the minus touch facebook
page
thank you to all the people out there
watching on facebook we are on the books
of face
and we are on twitter for the time being
have you noticed that we are in week
three of elon musk's twitter blue balls
have you noticed that this is week three
of elon musk buying twitter blue balls
i actually i mean i actually don't i
don't think this is gonna happen
i i think someone keeps leaking this
information to pump the [ __ ] stock
what do you guys think do you think elon
musk actually is gonna buy twitter
do you think that's [ __ ] real
do you think it's real i don't know i
don't think it's real
i don't know maybe
maybe it's just the
cynicism in me
[Laughter]
that believes elon musk
and twitter are full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're full of [ __ ] folks
they're full of [ __ ]
we got a lot of stuff to get to today
there was a lot of um
uh
a lot of news this weekend there's a lot
of news this morning uh we have news out
of ukraine
um
that um
anthony blinken and
secretary
austin has met with president zielinski
we also have some news about toyota and
their donation to insurrectionist
franklin graham is trending i have no
idea why probably because he's a [ __ ]
box um steve martin is trending for
uh some comedy he did 40 years ago uh
cat turd is trending not to be confused
with dog
turds when you have a trump rally i i've
been tweeting this every time there's a
trump rally i tweet
i would rather eat a big bag of dog [ __ ]
than go to a trump rally but cat turd
is trending we'll find out why i'm sure
it's the um the headquarters that true
social of course is trending stacy
abrams is trending as well but the big
story today the big story today
is is elon musk going to reinstate trump
on twitter because that's what
everyone's worried about i mean really
honestly
you know this fantasy this right-wing
nut fantasy that somehow elon musk is
buying twitter to reinstate trump you
are a bunch of dumb [ __ ]
you right-wing maga trump-humping idiots
you really think you horse-paced eating
[ __ ] you really think elon musk
is spending 43 billion dollars
just to let donald trump back on twitter
oh come on
you think the ego of elon musk is is
is gonna pump the ego of donald trump
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
i don't believe that for a second
not for a second do i believe
that elon musk is going to spend 43
billion dollars of his money just just
to help out the cheeto dust mobster
come on give me a [ __ ] break
i don't believe that's true we're gonna
get we're gonna get our co-host uh gabe
sanchez's
uh opinion on this when when we get him
on the show today hopefully he'll be
able to jump on for a while today
because he you know he he knows the
techie stuff
he's always making boomer jokes
about me
okay boomer i i mean i know technology i
grew up with you know video games and
cable tv and satellite television and
the intronet
but i i i'm not i'm not uh deep dive
into some of this stuff but i really
think i really think this twitter thing
elon musk buying twitter i think it's
all [ __ ]
i think it's all [ __ ]
i really do
i don't think his goal
is to buy twitter so that donald trump
can be back on on social media
i mean if that was the case why wouldn't
he just why wouldn't he just
buy true social for a buck and a half
not a share just like a buck and a half
i mean really honestly for 43 billion
dollars 43 billion dollars elon musk
could do what trump tried to do which is
totally [ __ ] copy twitter just copy
it just [ __ ] copy it he call it musky
or something musky social
i don't understand why people and i
don't understand why people think that
twitter's all sudden gonna [ __ ]
change it's a swamp now it's a swamp and
everyone's like oh well he's for freedom
of speech well they still have terms and
services
like he would have to go through the
whole process of changing their terms of
service
i mean yeah it could happen
because the accounts that are banned now
are banned now because of the current
terms of services
so he'd have to go through the process
of probably changing the terms of
services and then and then people would
have to appeal to the new terms of
services for their old account
i mean it's not just gonna be a [ __ ]
he snaps his fingers he brings in bags
of cash
you know 43 billion dollars worth and
twitter's like yeah go ahead go ahead do
whatever [ __ ] you want we're out and
then they all leave the building and
elon musk is sitting there at the
computer come on give me a [ __ ] break
that is not how this is gonna work
43 billion dollars it's not
if the [ __ ] twitter is acting and i
don't mean twitter itself but people on
twitter are acting like he's buying a
thousand dollar cash car is come on give
me a [ __ ] break number one we're not
even close we're not even close to him
purchasing twitter even if this is a
deal that can be made it he ain't gonna
buy this son of a [ __ ] at the end of
the month that it's not how it [ __ ]
works
it's not how it works everyone's
pointing up
um
everyone's saying something
oh
yeah the people are pointing out that he
that elon musk is doing it so that they
can spread around racism and hatred i
mean i mean that's what he calls free
speech right like that that that is a
good point i mean he's he's trying to
he's trying to make hate speech into
free speech which it's not
and again if you have terms of services
you have to have someone elon musk is
not going to be sitting at a desk
determining who is violating terms of
services and who is not
even the ceo of twitter does not
currently sit at a desk determining
every single account that is reported
that is in violation quote unquote of
their terms of service
and again legally it's a company it's
illegally they'd have to go through and
change their terms of service there's
going to be a room full of [ __ ]
lawyers this is not this is [ __ ]
absolute even if he'd bribes it and it's
a private company
and caitlyn's saying he's he would
fundamentally change twitter yeah that's
the fantasy
that's the fantasy
he uh he all he also wants to have a
colony in the outer space as well
elon musk has a lot of [ __ ] fantasies
a lot of [ __ ] fantasies and when you
when you grow up
being a blood diamond [ __ ] silver
spoon [ __ ]
and and you you you were afforded tax
dollars from our country to prop up your
[ __ ] electric car company to act like
you invented electric cars and you're
the only elect company out there that
can make [ __ ] electric cars
and that we should stop taxing you after
we have we have dumped tons of our tax
dollars our federal reserve into your
[ __ ] pocket
and you [ __ ] and moan and complain he's
got a lot of [ __ ] fantasies folks a
lot of [ __ ] fantasies elon musk is a
walking [ __ ] fantasy
a walking fantasy
so this idea that somehow he's gonna
walk in and kick over everything and
he's going to be sitting at the helm
working the only twitter computer there
and determining who's going to be and
have an account there is terms of
service folks it is a contract when you
say i agree to that terms of service you
are agreeing to it which means which
means you get to sue twitter
you think there's they're not going to
fend off make sure to fend off class
action lawsuits here
come on this is ridiculous to think that
all of a sudden elon musk is going to
snap his fingers
and twitter is just going to be
completely [ __ ] different number one
twitter is the way it is because the
model works
the model works
and yeah is he buying it for over value
sure sure and i'm not saying that elon
musk buying twitter is a good thing
i'm not saying that i don't think it's a
good thing i don't think it's a good
idea for one [ __ ] person who thinks
they're an evil genius
who thinks they're [ __ ] a
a cross between scrooge mcduck
and lex luthor
i don't think that's a good idea
and maybe just maybe it'll get the
[ __ ] attention of the united states
congress and some [ __ ] regulators
to realize that yes
some legislation needs to be passed
to help along our process of figuring
out what social media is and what we
need it to be and what we don't need it
to be in this country
and honestly if if elon musk gives us
blue balls every [ __ ] week on twitter
for the next six months because that's
how it's gonna take a long time to get
through this process
it's gonna take a long goddamn time
it's going to take a long time to work
through this process to make sure
that the deal is done
and my guess is at the end of the day
some form of elon musk owning twitter
which he already does own a portion of
twitter he already owns a portion of it
so we'll see we'll see but until the day
is and it's done
and they say yeah yeah
he owns it then i'll believe it
then i'll [ __ ] believe it
but until then [ __ ] elon musk
[ __ ] him
and [ __ ] anyone who's a sycophant of his
they all run around acting like he's
some kind of god the only reason why you
love him
is because he spits in the face of what
you consider to be woke but as soon as
he spits back in your face they'll
[ __ ] hate him they'll [ __ ] hate
him and i am waiting for the day that
manga realizes that elon musk isn't a
[ __ ] is it maga
elon musk is not manga he's not he's not
a conservative he's not a liberal he's
not woke he is just elon musk
he is out off in the universe of his own
and that's the way he likes it now we're
talking about him today and that's what
he wants
[ __ ] that's what twitter wants for
crying out loud you don't think twitter
wants to be the [ __ ] news here
you don't want you don't think twitter
wants everyone in the world to pay
attention to their stock price
hmm
so have no fear don't don't be afraid of
elon musk
he ain't he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
first place
he ain't gonna do [ __ ]
with twitter besides maybe buy it and
keep toying with buying it to pump the
price so they can have their their
successful pump and dumps
because i think ultimately that's sort
of what this is is it's pumping dumps
pumping dumps pumping dumps pumping
dumps
because these [ __ ]
morons out there these insol incel
crypto [ __ ]
these
these white in-cell white dudes who
think
crypto's a thing and elon musk is our
crypto god you know the you know what
i'm talking about you know what i'm
talking about
they're just trying to grift off those
[ __ ]
we have gabe sanchez here are you ready
gabe cause i i want you to talk about
this elon musk thing
let's let's bring gabe in here gabe the
how are you this morning i am good how
are you i'm pissed off none i mean
i really think that this elon mustang is
all [ __ ] i mean what what do you
think really i mean i mean give us your
honest opinion yeah i'll try to combat
if you're wrong
yeah yeah so uh do i think it
okay i think this is within the realm of
possibility right anything's possible i
think that after uh after trump was
involved
uh or got into presidency you know
the phrase anything's possible really
kind of took a downward meaning
um
but the way that i look at what's going
on with elon musk and twitter yes it's
definitely a possibility i think someone
is intentionally leaking this
information out
of
the twitter kind of negotiation sphere i
don't know if they're trying to use it
as a tactic to
kind of
uh throw throw like a bomb on
this to like blow it up or there's
someone that's trying to use it as a way
to
um drive up market value the stock so
like the pump and dump that right
exactly yeah so that's one way to do it
um
i mean elon owns a ton of stock and he
has a stun a ton of interest into
raising that stock price and then
selling it off to people who are like oh
elon musk is gonna buy twitter so right
here buy a bunch of stock and
unbeknownst to them they're buying the
stock overpriced and he's selling them
right it also wouldn't be outside the
realm of possibility that elon musk
would do that right because he has a
history of doing it in the past with
right yeah with tesla so um
do one even even with some of his crypto
like bitcoin and stuff like that yeah
don't do that
and really honestly
i think more than anything this story is
about not elon musk and not about
twitter i think this is more about uh
social media and the influence that
social media and influencers like elon
musk can have on our economy
and and how they can drive markets just
like donald trump would drive markets
when he was tweeting when he was the
president of the united states i
actually think that is probably the real
story here not that he's gonna buy it
because even if he does buy it what the
[ __ ] he gonna do you're not gonna do
anything and he can't just change
twitter overnight i mean he can change
it fundamentally over a period of time
but
to think that he can change the term of
services at a at just a flick of a
finger
is bonkers because there's going to be
rooms full of lawyers standing in his
way going you're going to get sued buddy
right and they're going to sue your ass
off which is going to drop the price of
your company and elon musk is not going
to do that he's not going to just he's
not i mean i think i think icy you sent
it to me he said he said
it wouldn't be cool if elon just shut
off twitter
uh iced tea
what was it
yeah yeah let me see if i can let me see
if i can find that uh here real quick um
yeah that was a good that was a good
tweet
gail thank you very much for the super
chat
uh let's see
let me see if i can find it here uh if i
can get my zoom to work this morning has
not been going well for me i'm getting
there
here it is iced tea says
it would be kind of dope it must brought
twitter bought twitter and just shut it
off
i mean honestly i don't know that this
is a bad idea for like a day or two a
couple years just to freak [ __ ]
people out yeah reset it shut it down i
mean it's a private company so he you
know whatever he wants right so i i do
look at this and i say yes it is
definitely within the wrong possibility
do i think what happened i don't know
i'm kind of like 50 50 right now because
you know he could be serious but then
elon in a lot of the ways that he works
especially on twitter itself he's just
trolling people right you look at this
past weekend he was trolling bill gates
about you know philanthropic
uh
uh
motives around uh climate change right
and right and also elon musk uh said
that his company was the leading
one of the the the foremost companies
leading companies in terms of uh
reducing or like uh going against
climate change which is [ __ ] right
i mean i mean this idea that electric
cars because electric you know seems
renewable well it depends on how you
[ __ ] make the electric like right
like a ton of states in this country red
states be specific but not not just red
states only they burn a ton of [ __ ]
fossil fuel to generate power a ton of
it a ton of it not all of our energy
electric specifically is is manufactured
with renewable sources like wind and
solar exactly and it's going to take a
long time to get there the other thing
the other thing that really pisses me
off about elon musk running around
acting like he's an environmentalist is
he wants to leave this planet number one
number two the guy the guy [ __ ]
constantly constantly talks about crypto
which crypto has been proven to be not
exactly environmentally friendly because
of how it has to be mined and how much
energy is used which goes back to
how are you producing electric so this
[ __ ] idea that he's some some sort of
environmentalist or whatever the [ __ ]
elon musk is out again i was saying this
earlier he's not he's not manga he's not
a lefty he's not a conservative he
really is not political in any sense of
the word just like trump was never
political trump wasn't he was just how
can i start a fire and pour gasoline on
it right like that's he's a provocateur
how do i how do i cause people to talk
about me and really honestly
do we see donald trump tweeting anyways
right like he puts out statements yeah
he's got liz harrington to put out
statements and he can do it more than
140 characters right right and and how
how irrelevant have those statements
become just absolutely irrelevant and
the reason why is because he is
irrelevant right to it to a certain part
of the national conversation he is
irrelevant the republican party [ __ ]
hates him all all the people but the
sycophants uh hate him or well pretend
to love him but they [ __ ] hate him
the moderates and independents see him
as a complete threat the generic ballot
she-ism is a complete threat to their
way of life
that's why they voted against him and
voted for joe biden and the left
certainly [ __ ] can't stand donald
trump right so this idea that somehow
elon musk is something different than
what donald trump is and i'm not saying
um he's he's he's a danger to our
country but i will tell you
whether this deal gets done or not i
think this points out a very very big
problem that we have in this country and
in this in the on the planet
with social media in general and what
what how in this new age because we live
in a new age right this is
yeah right social media and the
influence of social media is an infant
right just like when they invented the
printing press yeah right that was a
that was all yeah
relative to everything else like social
media is very new you know right exactly
well i mean
it's and it's and the influence of it is
even newer than that right like like
just in the last 10 years have we really
figured out that holy [ __ ] social media
has big social impacts big political
impacts economic impacts and this is a
prime example right a prime example of
this morning we're talking about how
elon musk is gonna buy twitter whoever
the [ __ ] leaked this out and here we go
here we go
the stock price is probably going to
rise and people are going to start
dumping stuff i mean if i look at
the twitter stock right now i would say
it's probably up it is up three and a
half percent as of right now there you
go 1.71 so you know i look at this whole
thing and yes there is so again there's
a possibility that elon musk could in
fact buy this you know he says he's got
the cash in hand you know the how many
ever billions at 52 40 or 40 250 i
forget right 43 something i think yeah
yeah well i think he was i think the
offer was just below 54 or something i
think
yeah
for per per uh right right yeah so which
means he's paying above market value now
obviously that might change based on how
the stock moves up right he could be
paying under market value if the stock
goes beyond the 54 i think 20 that it
that it was like priced at for the 43
billion right but it seemed like this
morning the story was is that he secured
the financing because we really got blue
balls on this right like three weeks ago
it was he was gonna buy a board seat and
then last week he was just gonna buy the
whole thing and they're like ah [ __ ]
you don't have the financing and they
were looking for a white knight really
like a venture capitalist yeah come in
and and so the reason that was happening
was because uh they're like well do you
have that many billion in like liquid
right now right can you pay us for it
and you pay us right and then the
concern was well in order to get that
money he would have to sell stock in uh
in tesla or spacex like he would have to
give up some sort of stake to get cash
turned over and then there's the concern
that well if he did that then that would
cause investors of those companies to
say whoa whoa
what are you doing this is not in the
best interest of our company that we are
stakeholders in because you're [ __ ]
no stakeholders right tesla exactly to
do whatever
brainiac thing you got going right i
think twitter's going to be for free
speech
who the [ __ ] complains i i tweet
anything i want almost as far as it's
not against the terms of service and
halftime i'm tweeting against terms of
service no one [ __ ] reports me right
like unless you're all and that really
goes to show you like oh everyone's like
oh i want free speech and there's
silence they're suppressing us it's like
well did you say something like did you
make a death threat did you say
something that was just like completely
homophobic racist transphobic like was
there something against a group that
that you should not have said was it
listed in the literal terms of service
that when you did not read it you just
clicked the box and said yes create
account that's on you right nobody okay
here's a thing nobody reads terms of
service nobody reads the privacy
policies they just click it and say okay
it's the same way when people who are
voting on a bill in congress in the
senate they don't read that [ __ ] they
just click a box and say yep i'm voting
for it or i'm not voting for it and this
is another example of people who are who
are in their faux outrage are
complaining about free speech when
twitter literally will let you say most
if not everything at all outside of some
things that are just just illegal and
you shouldn't say um
and so these people you know got upset
right the right wing the the the right
wing nut jobs the gqp whatever said you
know what i'm leaving twitter because
there's no free speech i'm gonna go for
the parlor right and then it's like okay
cool some people went over to parlor
they
talked about january 6th
then it was getter then it was right
then it was getting from jason miller
and then you know there was gab before
that then it was uh
then it was true social right which true
social doesn't even have trump on it
right and then you've got it right and
then you've got an interview with trump
and they're talking about you know like
are you gonna if you could be allowed
back on twitter would you go and he goes
oh you know twitter is uh really
silencing or silencing conservative
voices we're doing something really big
with our platform meaning truth social
or as he said it this weekend uh uh
toots tooth central i think is what he
said yeah yeah yeah
i mean he didn't even know that right
exactly so then you've also got devin
nunes who's saying like oh you know what
uh it's a boring place over there it's
just a bunch of fodder trump would never
join again you know and i look at that
too and i'm like trump
you know we chatted about this didn't
devin nunes say that true social got
more engagement than twitter
yeah yeah he said he said uh it was uh
he was like oh there's like a ghost town
over on twitter i think that's what he
actually said yeah 43 billion dollars
worth of a ghost down by the way
he's like it's a ghost town and uh
and true social is really having some
high engagement now from what i've read
and what i've seen through other people
because i'm still number 355 thousand on
the wait list for uh truth social just
to see what it's like but um
you you look at all these people who
complain about this stuff right they're
like oh my freedom of speech oh i'm
being silenced it's like you're
literally saying that
right now you're online screaming about
it
and no one is letting you and no one has
taken it down you can say whatever you
want you can complain you can [ __ ] you
can moan you can do whatever and you go
to these other places and there's gonna
be a mass exodus from twitter and we're
going over to gab and gitter and parlor
and choose social and then you look at
those places and they're the [ __ ]
ghost town they've got so small numbers
when it comes to engagement little
activity a bunch of bots you've got a
bunch of seated content in there to like
drive engagement and drive conversation
it doesn't it isn't real it's just yeah
it's not real it's just it's you know
they they develop it with a machine
right right exactly so yeah you look at
those people who are like um it's like
dude you said you were gonna leave you
said you were gonna leave to each one of
these things over the last two years
what happened and they just they cling
on and i think at the end of the day
these people who who stay on twitter
they speak klingon yeah they speak
klingon i know they cling on they on to
twitter they [ __ ] and moan about it
they cling onto twitter in the hopes
that they'll be able to you know get
their free speech back like they would
never gone in the first place right well
i mean this is a prime example when we
were when we were streaming uh ken says
here tooth central that was this did he
say tooth central is that what he said i
did he like slurred his words uh and so
he was like
true he was like two we got this great
place to central yeah he's like
he was like two truth truth central and
it's like dude that's not even a name
man like you got truth right but
yeah man the central he meant yeah
so friday we seen this in action right
right when marjorie taylor greene was
testifying meet you and karen um at
nipple oh from legal eight hours baby
eight hours all day friday actually uh
just give an announcement we actually i
actually
um we posted the the highlights three
and a half hours were the highlights we
were hoping to get it down to two but
well i took a break and i came back but
yeah you were you you you told me like
you said to everyone you're like i'm
gonna i gotta you know i gotta go run
some errands i'm gonna let the i'm gonna
let the feed run
i left to to do work and like take a
break and stuff and then i came back uh
near the end and
you were still going i was still there
you never even left i never left all
eight hours i was there i was there
all eight hours it was um
it was a long day it was a long day but
we got it in and you can go to the
youtube channel which you should go
subscribe to the youtube channel by the
way if you're out there on facebook or
twitch or twitter go subscribe to our
our youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast just type that in in the youtube
search bar it'll bring up and subscribe
you don't want to miss a video because
we cut that eight hours down into three
and a half well just over three and a
half
um of highlights with me and karen but
the point i was trying to make about we
seen this on friday this whole
[ __ ] about how i'm banned from
twitter is marjorie taylor green right
and she completely [ __ ] gets the
facts all twisted on the stand
under oath which yeah is going to be
questionable rather she committed
perjury in some of those instances and i
think one of the most significant
doesn't have to do with the social media
it has to do with who she contacted on
january 6th right but that's beside the
point i digress the point that i was
trying to make about her testimony
but she said
i'm banned from twitter which one of her
accounts is currently permaband and she
tweeted this morning and she tweeted
back
yeah right it which is
it it boggles my mind that she claims
she's not on twitter she runs around all
these american first things saying her
free speech is being suppressed and
she's not on twitter and she's not
allowed to tweet this morning she
[ __ ] tweeted that her other account
is permaban she tweeted from her
congressional account because every
member of congress is afforded an
official congressional account to tweet
from she can tweet and she said me me i
i in this tweet it was not her staffer
tweeting this this right right let me
see if i can pull that up because i
wanna i'm gonna the woman who also
because on friday she was like well i
i've had many people work for me and
they i don't know what people have liked
or commented and it's like
okay
if you are letting someone else run your
account and you have no final say or
approval or just kind of oversight to
know exactly what people are doing that
sounds like a pretty uh
pretty uh
let's say
unqualified boss right like if you can't
manage the content or the employees and
what they're doing it sounds like maybe
you shouldn't be doing that at all it
sounds like maybe you're just
unqualified to be a congressperson it
seems like you're just letting people do
whatever they want and then you're going
to either yes take credit or not take
credit and pass the buck to them and
place blame on them which means that you
shouldn't be doing the job that you have
right well i mean
that's fair to say she shouldn't be
doing the job she has and technically
she's not even hardly well yeah she's
not a congress person right yeah but
here she is um she's tweeting this
morning about how she can't tweet
basically prepare for blue
blue check mark full-scale meltdown
after elon musk uh seals the deal which
that's a [ __ ] lie that's a lie the
news is is that he's procured the
financing right and that twitter is
considering
the financing that he has procured
they're not saying that it's a done deal
he's not bagging up cash in duffel bags
to take down to twitter like it's a
[ __ ] cash car that he's buying for
the thousand bucks this is [ __ ]
stupid and she says and should i
i should get i she says i here she is
tweeting even if her staff is tweeting
it doesn't [ __ ] matter because this
is her account and it says i should get
my my personal account restored so she
wants to be off twitter
but she's tweeting about how she wants
to be on and i also think like even
friday when she used that she used that
excuse of like oh people you know i have
a bunch of people working for me i don't
know what they like or what they
commented it's like no no no no
uh
you know if you want to bring those
people in and you want to answer the
question i'm like who liked it who is
running those pages fine totally however
at the end of the day
it's your brand your personality right
that one took an action
and liked something that said for
instance there was the there was the
thing is like how did we get nancy
pelosi out of our like remove house
speaker nancy pelosi and then she liked
a comment that said a bullet to the head
would be quicker right so
whether she liked it or not it's her
account which means that is a
representation of her voice
so i look at that i'm like there's no
real excuse here
that can be had i will say one thing i
hope elon musk if he does budget or he
changes this [ __ ] look at this every
single time
every single time more twitters don't
post replies like that what the f i post
replies like this all the time twitter
and you haven't caught on we're asking
tweeters to re review replies with
potentially harmful and offensive
language well guess what [ __ ] that [ __ ]
your tweet sucks margery taylor green
tweet that [ __ ]
so so i mean in this and this goes back
to the terms of service right because i
think that's what a lot of people are
missing and what marjorie taylor green
and her tweet is missing here is that
even if elon musk buys twitter he can't
just snap his fingers and bring back
permaban accounts and the reason why is
because there is a term of service it's
it's not like this is it it's not like
this is bazooka bubble gum right and and
it's got a warning on it this this is
serious [ __ ] [ __ ]
twitter is worth billions of dollars
regardless if elon musk overpays or not
right they are they are potentially
liable for any lawsuits where they break
their terms of service and if they let
if they let her back but they don't let
a bunch of other accounts back
in the same violation there could be
class action lawsuits that be brought
against twitter over and over here
here's anyone wondering i will tell you
uh i will tell you how it works from a
engineering and product
uh kind of you're talking about social
media in general well just like working
at a company like i can tell you from
experience what it works what how this
actually happens right so let's say that
somebody the ceo right so let's say that
elon musk owns it he becomes a ceo
you know i'm not sure what his role
would be if he owns it right like if he
would probably place board members chair
or whatever but he comes in because
here's the thing you have a board and
the board says uh hey we want to do we
want to work on this we want to do this
right and then the executive team
ceo
um the the chief product officer and
others who are actually working on this
will then say okay we'll go back and
we'll we'll figure out if we can do it
or vice versa they say hey we're working
on this feature we want to let you guys
know when the board says great right and
they can vote it up or down and say yes
or no because that's how boards work
now
if they say you know what elon says as
the owner of the company he wants to
bring these people back so right he's
got a list of people that have been
blacklisted in permaban he wants to
bring them back
yes again
they have to review to say what the
terms of service are now on the other
side something you mentioned too is when
it comes to lawyers i can tell you from
experience
i have tried to we
through previous work we have tried to
change subtle things at past companies
just single single pizza bits of
language in the actual terms of service
right to say like oh i mean the company
itself
as a user you can do xyz right or you
have to refine exactly you have to be
very precise on how you say things
because that what you want to make sure
that you're guarded legally from any
sort of lawsuit or any sort of issue
right so then what happens is you send
it to your lawyers you got a team of
lawyers they review it they send it back
to you redlining and say actually you
can't say this you need to describe it
this way they say well it's not quite
how this is then you have to describe
what the product is what the feature is
how it changes why you need to change
the terms of service then they go back
and lawyers say okay well we gotta
adjust the language here we gotta uh
tweak this here to make sure that no one
can just find a loophole and sue the
company and make some sort of lawsuit
right because
as the lawyers you want to protect the
company and the board also wants to
protect their investment in terms of
the company not just ultimately failing
and going down
then you go to the product side which is
hey
i'm a product manager and we want to
have this feature right whether it's
like the edit button or something like
that or it could be hey we want to like
flip the switch on all these people wait
wait wait you mean elon musk will bring
an edit button
i'm just saying he there are a lot of
people out there on twitter that are
going well maybe this elon musk ain't so
bad right right right i mean here's the
thing you can you can bring an edit
button in
i think there should be a certain time
constraint to how how soon after you can
change it but also there should be an
edit history so you can show that this
was edited right now like just show an
archive right right so that way you
don't have someone saying there were a
billion people
at the border that were apprehended and
they switch it to a million and be like
i never said that and it's like no right
you actually brain well so well
so the main thing though is is that
regardless of what happens here elon
musk is not just gonna fire everyone at
twitter and run twitter from his laptop
number one elon musk probably doesn't
even really work at a laptop he probably
doesn't even
[ __ ] sit in front of one yeah again
remember elon musk he's not a genius
he's not a smart man [ __ ] i can tell
you again from two people that have
worked with him at spacex one is a
literal rocket scientist like literally
a rocket scientist that's that's like
his title like if he had a business
guard yeah he'd be like john doe rocket
rocket scientist yeah yeah he's like
well it doesn't take a rocket people
actually i am a rocket scientist
and another one who did marketing at
tesla and work directly with elon musk
and they said like he is
he is
uh clever in ways around like how to
navigate business and he can absorb
information
and regurgitate it back out with some
understanding but he's not like this
i'm an einstein i'm a genius i'm someone
who's able to just he's not a micro man
he's like right yeah yeah yeah like he's
i mean he's the 40 000 he's the 40 000
foot guy right right he's the 40 000
foot guy that sees an image of of what a
company could be and and really i mean
it's not like he's self-made that's all
[ __ ] he's not self-made he didn't
invent electric cars [ __ ] yeah
he's not that [ __ ] brilliant
he did
right not good and all the and
for someone here's the other thing too
for someone and you can look it up let
me i'll show you that i'll i'll send you
the tweet but for someone like elon musk
who says oh free speech you know but i'm
gonna you know bring out the facebook he
is someone who actually will pay to dig
up dirt and and accuse journalists of
things that do not have actual substance
to them just to ruin their image right
so like you know i mean i mean he
participates in cancer culture is that
what you're saying exactly
i mean here's here's the thing here's
the thing is that this idea that elon
musk is going to run the entirety of
twitter all by himself and make all the
decisions is really [ __ ] boneheaded
it is really if you've ever watched one
interview with this guy
this guy can barely keep the saliva in
his mouth i mean at some points in
interviews and the tears in his eyes he
is such a
melted puddle of ice cream most of the
time and he wouldn't be able to run
twitter all by himself give me a break
and he and he's he's probably going to
have the brightest minds helping him run
twitter and what i mean by that is the
people who run it now like twitter is
very successful that's why he wants to
buy it for 43 million 43 billion dollars
otherwise he'd just go by true social
and i was saying this this morning for
43 billion dollars elon musk could do a
heavy lift and get a social media
platform what's also funny is i think
that there was a i think there was a an
offer that said hey elon if you don't
want to invest in twitter come over i
think it might have been gab
uh that was offered to like to purchase
it was like hey it was the same here's
the thing
same offer that was made uh i think it
was on rumble uh that was made to joe
rogan right oh you're getting canceled
oh yeah yeah you're getting silenced
right hey the left is trying to woke you
out of it you're like
joe
will pay you
double what we'll pay you a hundred
million two hundred million for this
deal right
and everyone's like oh my god you should
totally do that
this and that and then it turns out oh
you know what joe rogan actually doesn't
want to take the deal right because he's
like it's not actually smart move and
there's actually not the engagement i
would see that i do on spotify this same
thing goes with elon musk when one when
other people like gab and others say
like hey listen you want to buy for 43
billion we'll put the money in our
company and we can do great things
meanwhile illinois is like nah [ __ ] that
that place is like a [ __ ] ghost town
these places are just echo chambers that
are just reverberating in within each
other of people saying the same [ __ ] and
they're not really actually engaged
people versus twitter which is like yeah
it's a free speech platform mind you as
as long as you're keeping you know along
with the actual like terms of service
but you can say crazy things on the
right you can say crazy things on the
left you could say crazy things in the
middle it doesn't matter but the
difference between twitter and other
places like gab parlor getter truth
social is that everyone's saying the
same [ __ ] thing everyone's pushing
the same conspiracies everyone's pushing
the same hate right and yeah you could
probably say those vile disgusting
bigoted transphobic homophobic whatever
things over there but you're not going
to find anyone who's actually going to
debate you and the reason that these
right-wing nut jobs stay on twitter
is to drive the hate
they they want someone to argue with
right because on those other platforms
it's just everyone's saying hey i've got
this idea or i've got this theory or
i've got this this thought about
something and everyone else says yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes i agree but on
twitter there's actual debate discussion
people who are like no [ __ ] you man
that's not so right i'm gonna report you
i'm gonna do this
that's the difference between those
platforms and twitter
on those platforms
nothing is really there's no substance
it's just say one thing and everyone
says yeah okay crook that's that sounds
good right everyone's just saying the
same thing it's just an echo chamber but
on twitter there's actually a different
discussion that's happening right
there's actual people because they were
right well they were first to this to
this model right this this archive type
model um which is a little different
than the other social media platforms
let's bring up this tweet that you
showed uh ken says good vibes for buster
um we're trying to adopt a new dog
thanks tony gabe you guys were
marathoners friday we did it thank you
for
joining us yeah on friday and uh
um congratulations on trying to adopt a
new dog ken thanks for the super chat um
you you sent this tweet it says no clue
musk will make twitter worse i again i i
i don't think um
twitter could get much
worse but um uh but anyone who believes
musk cares about protecting speech
please um
again this provides some of the evidence
um
elon musk paid a private investigator
fifty thousand dollars to dig up dirt on
a british uh cave rescue or he called a
pedo guy is this is this the part where
he was trying this was the thing where
they were trying to rescue that uh team
right
and he was like i'll send a thing in
underneath the cave to save the kids or
whatever right because he's so [ __ ]
smart and so intelligent and here it
turns out that his idea didn't work yeah
it sucks um and then here's when elon
musk tried to destroy a tesla
whistleblower here's another story uh
when he tries to
cancel someone quote unquote he was
being woke he was being hey all hey all
you hey all you right-wingers out there
elon musk is awoke [ __ ] which i
i believe that's really the thing i
can't wait for it's like if he actually
does my twitter i can't wait
for him to [ __ ] all over these
right-wing fantasies of what twitter's
gonna be and when it's not gonna be it's
gonna be hilarious um elon musk
personally cancels blogger's tesla order
after rude post yep holy [ __ ] are you
kidding me
so he's like nope you don't get a car is
it is it that's pretty much what
happened he was like you said something
i don't agree with you were mean so as a
result
i'm not going to give you your car that
you paid for
right so you look at you look at this
and it's just like oh oh free speech
free speech oh my god and then you find
out that actually elon musk is someone
who is willing and okay to suppress the
voice
and the actual uh uh speech of others
right they're right which is not to say
it's too far different from what
republicans do right now right they they
complain about it and then if they don't
like you they block you it's like well
if you're gonna do one you should pick a
lane you either
don't want free speech and you want it
restricted to only the voices that you
agree with or you want an open
discussion regardless of haters or or
people who agree with you and you just
gotta pick one but you can't have your
cake you need it too right right well i
mean it's the same way as like anyone
who thinks that um
elon musk owning it
is going to destroy twitter like that
that's kind of the opposite of the point
is that twitter isn't going to sell off
twitter
to destroy it because there's there's
going to still be financial stake
in it and by that i mean that elon musk
is not going to walk in with bags of
cash he doesn't have this money under
his mattress i mean
there are banks if anyone remembers the
story of a guy uh what's that guy's name
from the early 90s it destroyed casinos
and he went bankrupt uh he was disgraced
i forgot he was supposed to be some big
real estate guy oh he turned out to be a
[ __ ] fraud do you remember that guy
what's his name donald trump oh okay
that's his name you know you know what's
funny about that guy is in the early 90s
when he bankrupt
all the [ __ ] companies that he owned
the banks that he owed money to they
told him you can't do this you can't do
that you can't do this you can't do that
because they had a financial interest
and there was a contract a note that
they could tell him what he could and
couldn't spend money on especially when
you go into receivership so this idea
that somehow elon musk can just do away
with terms of service no terms of
service he can just automatically change
it without no without without any
consequence in the court of law is a
bunch of [ __ ] it's [ __ ] really
stupid to to think that he is he is
buying a lemonade stand for 43 billion
dollars because that's what some people
it feels like to me think is happening
right that that this process by the end
of the week elon musk is going to own
twitter literally if this is a deal we
probably won't have an actual
transaction until sometime next year in
the calendar year of next year yeah i
don't know when it would happen but i
can tell you this again like from the
product development standpoint if people
are like oh we want these features to do
xyz right okay there well there's a
there's a lot that has to happen before
you can just like flip a switch and say
it's on right there's the ideation
you've got a you've gotta uh test wait
wait wait tell us what ideation is
ideation is when you have an idea and
you look at it and you say like oh it
would be like we'll just use the edit
button as an instance right like oh it
would be great if twitter had an edit
button so you're saying they have an
idea and then they have to go through
the process of actually implementing it
yeah they're having their platform but
in across their terms
but what happens is then they go and say
okay let's we want to introdu
we have a theory that if we we could
increase engagement uh
and daily active users or whatever the
metric might be to say if we include an
edit button we can retain people on the
platform longer whatever it is right and
they say okay well you want to test that
theory so then so then they say a
product manager will say oh well here's
a wireframe here's an idea of how it
might work you know or a designer works
on it then the designer says okay well
cool let me let me refine the elements
here figure out the the user experience
how the actual interaction would work
you know what would happen in these
different uh
cases right like when i send a tweet
when i know how to fix a tweet when i
want to approve a fixed tweet or
whatever it is and then they say okay
cool cool so you've got some mock-ups
you got some wireframes i want you now
to go test that with actual users right
now you could either do two things one
is you do testing through some sort of
low fidelity way which is uh just like a
quick like sketches another way is that
you could actually implement this thing
which requires some coding and some
actual uh engineering time and then
because twitter had to build
infrastructure on the site right exactly
now now so what happens is then they
then they test it then they they try to
validate it and they say does this
actually work the way that we want do
people find it very easy to use uh are
they able to understand it without a lot
of explanation you know kind of that
type of thing
and then
uh they
they say okay these were the results
from that testing that we did and they
say great okay uh hypothesis validated
or invalidated and we're going to go
forward or not go forward with it or
we're going to refine it and then go
back through the steps
and and keep working through this cycle
and then at that point that's when they
say all right as a pm a product manager
hey engineering team we've got this
feature we want to build which is the
edit button and here are the different
ways that it looks when it's in these
different states here's how it would
function here's how people would
interact with it and then engineering
says great this is how long it would
take us for us to build right and they
say it would take us a couple weeks
through uh test
uh testing and
actually building this out and doing
this and then obviously before we
actually launch it we want to then test
it with a small sample size right you
want to make sure that people are
actually able to use it now what's going
on that's why some people will get
released
certain features before anyone else
right you'll be like oh i've got a
different layout on twitter or i've got
a different feature over here that it
has like what the [ __ ] mine looks
exactly the same exactly right and
you're like why didn't get that it's
just because you were they're testing it
their twitter twitter decided you were
you fit a certain uh core group and from
there they said
uh you get it or you don't get it and
then based on those results they say
great it's stable nothing's broken we
can keep this working
and then they say great go live i mean
just look at the down vote the down vote
has been pulled and brought back and
pulled and brought back several times
on on twitter comments right right they
haven't actually landed on whether
they're going to do it or not they keep
testing it so for someone to say like oh
yeah we would have changed this and
change that over there didn't they do
some sort of like a reels thing or what
was the [ __ ] well they had it
it wasn't really had store it was called
flights and they had flights yeah that
is time and then they just completely
where where is that where is that it's
gone oh oh you mean you mean they decide
based on market i want to bring up a
comment here from from facebook speaking
of this uh diana says oh my listening to
you two little socialists is hilarious
the funny part about this comment is
everything we're describing here is
capitalism you dumb [ __ ]
everything that we're describing is
capitalism it's market-driven it's
consumer-driven and that's what i'm
actually saying if you would open your
[ __ ] ears and listen i'm actually
saying it's not gonna be that big of a
deal if elon musk does make this deal
you dip [ __ ] i also like how keeping
that keeping the algorithm keep
commenting because i understand how
social media works and you calling me a
socialist in the comments come and call
me a socialist every day come hate watch
we love you we'd love to have you here i
also really enjoy when somebody says
yeah well socialist thing is whatever
but for someone to tell me like i don't
know what i'm talking about i was like
dude listen i've spent the last 11 to 12
years working specifically within tech
from the marketing sales engineering and
you've been producing free market part
of tech exactly
yeah a lot of a lot of private money
going into startups where i've worked
and doing exactly what we're talking
about right now right for social media
you know what's funny about this person
on facebook here she probably she
probably loves elon musk but doesn't
know that [ __ ] has taken more of
our goddamn tax dollars to run his
companies
than any other i mean literally tesla
exists because of taxpayer dollars you
dip [ __ ] because of socialism you dumb
[ __ ] so good luck to you keep
tweeting keep coming or
whatever you do on facebook keep coming
here and keep commenting keep keep
driving our algorithms chris and gives a
smile because chris in as always uh our
local hate watcher we love to have you
here chris and uh don't think we forgot
about you well anyways anyways uh here's
a poll that we put out this morning on
the podcast page um we are now on week
three of twitter blue balls uh do you
think elon musk will actually buy
twitter
this time it is it is like neck and neck
here gabe
neck neck so everyone go vote on this
bowl
so we get a good idea of yeah
whoever's leaking this
this info to reuters and other and wall
street journal right whether they're
trying to use it as a as a means to uh
as a catalyst for this deal to go
forward or they're just trying to
inflate the stock value and the price
and then you know pump and dump as we
were talking about or they're like oh
i'm afraid this isn't happening um or i
don't want to happen and i want these
things there's like different ways in
which how you leak information about
this stuff but when you look at this
situation right now uh they said
supposedly that by the end of monday or
early tuesday a deal
would be finalized that they could
announce so we might find out
potentially by the end of the day that
this is happening or to what extent it
may or may not be happening right um so
yeah i don't know like if it's like if
it's a real [ __ ] thing and right and
i think
i think they're because they're just
they're they're um
right now what we've what we've seen so
far is that twitter is has become more
open-minded because according to this
because elon has proven that he can come
up with the because last week it was
like 43 billion okay but what are you
where are you gonna [ __ ] it out at right
like where are you going to [ __ ] it out
whose money are you going to take there
was no [ __ ] proof that elon musk was
even serious about the 43 billion last
week as far as twitter was concerned and
now elon apparently has provided some
proof to twitter that he is willing to
explore ways to make sure he has enough
liquid cash to do the deal and that's
all twitter is interested in not the
actual deal itself they're just entering
interested in the possibility of being
liquid are you staying with us after
this break for a little bit are you
gonna have to i have to jump okay um
well let's go to a break and when we
come back because i have several videos
that i wanna that i wanna show um and i
don't know before we go have you seen
this uh don jr eric greitens video i'm
going to show that to everybody
uh yeah well you sent it to me yeah yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious these two
[ __ ] weak ass alpha cucks don jr
loves
guns oh and and it makes them it makes
them a real tough guy you know this is
the stupid [ __ ] about about these second
amendment [ __ ] they think that guns
make them tough and [ __ ] uh okay hold on
one second we got something from caitlyn
says donald trump just found a contempt
of court fined ten thousand per day
until he complies oh so this is news it
looks like we have breaking news uh
donald trump is going to be fined ten
thousand dollars a day until he complies
with his contempt accord i guess is this
for the uh the new york attorney general
i guess would be yeah this is coming
from the civil case against trump or not
the criminal case yeah against trump
borg well gabe thanks for the breakdown
thanks for the breakdown on the the
social medias
and elon musk i guess if anything
social and social media stands or is
short for socialists i guess so
i guess diana from facebook should
probably get off facebook because it's
social social media social and i bet
there's some sort of in the terms of
service of facebook there's probably
like an acronym that that is crt
somewhere in there yeah definitely so
it's probably part of woke disney and
the woke left so maybe maybe she should
just think about finding somewhere else
speaking of of crying trumpers stick
around in the break you're going to have
a great great break here because the
trump fund is inside this break gabe
thanks for joining us everyone stick
around we'll be right back after this
break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
with us through the break
i have some video i want to break down
want to react to
i got boneheads out there i think i
think we scared diana off on facebook i
think she ran away scared what do you
guys think maybe she's still out there
you still out there diana you still
think we're socialist even though we're
talking about free market [ __ ]
what a dumbass this is typical manga
[ __ ] just like the the video i have up
here on the screen typical [ __ ] they
think like this is this is um if you
look here close this is don jr here
uh booger sugar junior you know the
cokehead that is
uh donald trump's the former president's
son
and who who who is the laptop we should
actually be looking for the cell phone
and the burners we should actually be
looking for the projection is strong
with this one and then we have eric
greitens
the the sex assaulter you know the the
former disgraced missouri governor who
duct taped his hairdresser to his
treadmill in his basement made her get
naked and took pictures of her while she
was blindfolded
and then
made her do sex acts
so that way he could use the pictures as
blackmail yeah that guy that [ __ ] guy
right there
eric greitens and don't don't believe me
when i say this [ __ ] about eric greitens
believe the republicans in missouri the
republicans in missouri are the ones
who did the investigation against eric
greitens and published the findings
which found that he duct taped his
hairdresser naked blindfolded to a
treadmill in his basement i'm not
[ __ ] you that [ __ ] is real you know
what else is real eric greitens is
running for united states senate in the
state of missouri
and kimberly guilfoyle is part of his
campaign or some [ __ ]
that's why booger sugar junior here
decided to go up and have a tough guy
moment on camera because that's all this
is
you ever met the guy in a bar who talks
a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] who's gonna beat
everyone's ass oh he's gonna kick your
ass and he's gonna kick your ass and
he's gonna do this he's gonna do that
all that [ __ ] and then you get out
on the sidewalk and that that
[ __ ] gets his face pounded in
because he's all [ __ ] talk
all
talk
yeah that's what these two are all
[ __ ] talk
everyone's saying this is dangerous and
of course it's [ __ ] dangerous because
they're sending a dog whistle
to people who are actually [ __ ]
dangerous
who would actually do the [ __ ] that
they're saying in the video
that's what they're doing here folks
they wouldn't actually do it they're a
bunch of [ __ ] they'd get their asses
kicked on the sidewalk in front of a bar
eric greitens and donald trump jr both
let's just watch this video let me make
it bigger for you so you can see
all the nonsense in this video
listen really closely to what don jr
says and then listen to what eric
greitens says we'll watch it a couple of
times so you can catch it
oh so tough so tough they can shoot a
target whew baby bang bang bang bang
bang pew pew pew pew pew no liberal can
pick up a gun and shoot a target that's
not a thing liberals just can't handle
guns and shoot get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] liberals own guns dummies
liberals own a lot of [ __ ] guns
and frankly liberals are smarter with
their [ __ ] weapons i would say and
probably have less accidents fatal
accidents for that matter but let's
listen to what don jr says here strikes
your fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere
striking fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere you i don't fear you you dumb
[ __ ] and honestly if i was ever
approached by with with donald trump jr
and he had a [ __ ] rifle in his hand
it would just piss me off more than
anything it would piss me off more for
him to approach me if he had a firearm
than if he didn't have one it would just
piss me off more
and i feel that way about anyone with a
firearm if you gotta walk around with a
[ __ ] firearm so you can order a
subway sandwich you are a [ __ ] you are
a [ __ ] weak piece of [ __ ] you are a
[ __ ] snowflake if you gotta carry
around a gun feel tough
that's what you are just like donald
trump booger sugar junior here
and eric greitens in tow listen to what
this [ __ ] says
liberals beware
did you catch it
did you catch it he said liberals beware
liberals beware let's listen strike your
fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere in the heart and the striking
fear in the hearts of liberals
everywhere and then listen
liberals beware liberals beware what a
bunch of [ __ ]
what a bunch of goddamn snowflake
[ __ ]
that they have to
oh and a bunch of [ __ ] boxes they think
they're so [ __ ] tough
they think liberals are scared
of boneheads with guns you are a dumb
stupid son of a [ __ ]
if you think liberals are scared with a
of a bunch of boneheads with guns really
[ __ ] stupid okay there's some more
footage i want to show you here this
video has nothing to do with politics
but it is a crazy ass video that i found
on the internet this morning i don't
know who retweeted it but i seen it you
guys got to watch this
pay attention to this motorcycle here
you see this motorcycle hit the car and
something fell off it looks like bodies
um and it actually is a a child and a
mother watch this
holy [ __ ]
look how close that mother pulled that
child back
it almost feels like that's what women
would do for the country maybe someone
should edit this and
make make uh women
um save the united states and democracy
in general did you guys see what
happened in france you guys would see
what happened in france
le pen was because not all women are for
democracy okay
not on women are for democracy
le pen is a putin's puppet paid bought
and paid for to create chaos in france
she gets her ass stomped by macron who
was very unpopular very unpopular well
let's watch this video again one more
time because it is crazy
go retweet this it look at that [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
god damn so close
i mean by the hair their chinny chin
chin
uh go retweet that video if you can it's
crazy i'll retweet to put it at the top
of the timeline here um i ended some
more video i want to show you um
the right wing's all losing their mind
about about joe joyanne reed
uh joy um did a couple stories on the
readout they're probably going to bang
me up for this video on youtube so i
might have to silence it after the fact
but we're going to listen to it here
live
so here is how to do fascism for fun and
profit if you are florida governor ron
desantis you start out by making it
illegal for schools to make white
children feel discomfort while being
taught about our nation's history of
racial discrimination and violence that
includes banning certain books but not
just history books or english literature
no no now even math books are being
banned in the not so free state of
florida last week the florida department
of education rejected 41 of math
textbooks for one key reason many of
those books contained prohibited topics
including alleged references to critical
race theory
now of course they did not provide any
actual example so that that is
you guys seen their their uh
they're
banning the
the books for crt the macbooks
i know someone showed me that that it
had some kind of acronym for crt and
that's where they're getting that from
probably not not surprising
um but i guess the reason why the right
wing is pissed off because joy here said
something about
when ron desantis signed the the bill
to um
to discriminate against people of
history in history when they teach
history they can't teach they can't
teach the actual history
that makes it to where the white man is
evil the white men enslaved black men
like they can't teach that history
you know what
they just want to teach history
but the republicans don't want to teach
history because if you actually knew the
truth oh my god you would disagree with
them that black people bad
and crt bet like you would disagree with
them you know you make white children
feel guilty no their parents feel guilty
my children don't feel guilty you dumb
sons of [ __ ]
i'm speaking of ron desantis
and uh florida passing laws
uh and banning curriculum you guys know
these two [ __ ] of course it's ron
desantis here and then uh we all know
him
the the eye patch guy
stuart rhodes who is the founder of the
oath keepers
um ty ross here he's gotta go
follow the uh ty ross
uh you gotta go follow her she's writing
a lot of articles on oath keepers lately
and i've been enjoying them
uh ty wright's anti-inclusive censorship
group group excuse me florida citizens
alliance the fca
driving force behind ron desantis book
bands so this is the group that's trying
to ban books
in florida florida's if i can get this
thing to work the florida citizens
alliance
is the one that is trying to ban books
in florida and pushing ron desantis and
the legislator to do so
the craziest part
is
in that organization's um
partners groups of partners it names the
oath keeper it names far-right gun
organizations and white nationalist
group as partner in their hate build
agenda
uh go follow tai and you can click the
link here on aki but she writes for
occupy democrats and she's been writing
a lot of articles
about the oath keepers and how they're
influencing our politics in this country
not just not just uh the
the unlawful insurrection that they
committed or tried to commit the cheeto
dust kangaroo coup
but also how their group is trying to
affect politics you guys know that we've
had stewart rhodes as a strange son and
has a strange ex-wife
tasha and dakota adams on our show
you really should go
subscribe to our youtube channel and
make sure that you catch those those
interviews
just go to our youtube channel we have a
playlist of the oath keeper and proud
boys clips
go over there we have the interviews
with tasha and dakota adams there
we've interviewed coda a couple times i
believe and and tasha was on for one she
even describes how stuart rhodes
got his eye patch in that interview
let's go check that out make sure to
subscribe
to the youtube channel
uh
let's move on here down the timeline if
i can get this thing to do what i want
did i i gave ty credit if we read it we
give credit um oh yes here we go
remember last week elon musk one was
gonna buy twitter
and and the week before that next monday
is gonna be a party like we're gonna do
this we're gonna do this stupid elon
musk thing
for [ __ ] weeks and probably months
probably months someone had a really
good take
um here
it was outspoken she says
you're not leaving twitter shut up
no i'm not going anywhere i'm staying on
twitter so are you don't act like you're
leaving get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] that's like saying you're
gonna move out of the country if donald
trump is elected you didn't go anywhere
you stayed right where you were
oh here's a good one from mayo mail's
one of our favorite i think mayo was in
the chat earlier when she
she's still here mayo says
every twitter account will come with a
free brain chip elon musk you know that
elon musk wants to put brain chips in
people like literally the right wing
screams and yells they're trying to put
chips in you with the vaccine oh my god
they're gonna put a computer chip in you
to mind control you and elon musk is
running around their [ __ ] hero is
running around going hey
i want to put i want to put
computer chips in
uh
oh oh i cut the video off too soon
everyone wants me and robin wants me to
play the joy video let me play the rest
of the joy we'll play the rest of the
joy video
i i aim to please here on the tony
michaels podcast so we'll play the rest
of her video i was going to move on just
a bit but
we'll play the rest let's see sound
familiar do you know who not only worked
for the company for 25 years but was
also a co-ceo
why virginia's newly elected republican
governor glenn younkin yes i think this
is this is uh this is what you're
talking about robin because this is
where uh joy is going with it i she's
trending because the right wing freaked
out
she they freaked out because she called
she said that ron desantis having black
kids
um in
standing behind him while signing an
anti-crt bill while he's banning black
history in florida in florida schools
she said it was child abuse and they
lost their [ __ ] minds
um but
to to robin's credit here i'm going to
finish the uh the
the clip here because joy is making a
good point
uh on the side of of the book bands is
that they're making profit from it right
they're trying to ban the books that
they already have so they can write new
ones and enter new curriculum and guess
who owns the company hmm same glenn
yunkin who campaigned on fake crt
hysteria last year and kicked off the
right election strategy for the culture
it is quite a coincidence that suddenly
the carlisle owned company will supply
the only approved math textbooks that
apparently won't make white children
somehow feel personally responsible for
long dead oh those poor white parents
feeling guilty for their children
because that's what's happening
could you have you ever ever met someone
like this who feels guilty about history
feels guilty about slavery i'm i'm white
i'm sure some of my family were slave
owners if you go back in history and
look it up i'm sure i have family
members that were here for
decade now some of them came in the late
19th century
but some of them before that so i may
have slave owners in my lineage but i
don't feel guilty because i just it's
i'm not responsible but it doesn't mean
that i don't have to know about it and
it doesn't mean that i don't have to
know the history and know why we are
where we are because of that history
it's really [ __ ] simple just because
you know the truth doesn't mean you have
to feel guilty about it especially if
it's truth that you personally had
nothing to do with but the thing is is
you can learn from the truth you can
learn from history you know they say
history repeats itself only if you let
it
and we let it
we let it and joy's making a good point
here but let's let her finish or
otherwise
robin will
will get onto me here in the comments
white adults doing bad things
and just as supreme chairman desantis
has set the authoritarian socialist
agenda for other red state governors to
follow it will be interesting to see
which other states not only take the
same steps in banning math textbooks
alongside tony morrison books and
anything about lgbtq people
but ultimately which red state decide
that the only option is to order from
this same company thus fattening this
same company's pockets that would be
quite a win for yunkan who as of last
year was reported to hold more than
6.7
million
shares of the carlyle group
and that is how to do fascism for fun
and profit
joy brings up a good point and that's
why the fascists get pissed
they get pissed off because joy brings
up the good good points
okay let's uh go on there's a toyota
story going around um judd has it here
update in july 2021 toyota issued a
press release stating it quote decided
to stop contributing to those members of
congress who contested the certification
of certain states in the 2020 election
you know the insurrectionists marjorie
taylor green lauren bobert mo brooks
the likes of him andy biggs paul gozar
madison just on and on matt getz all the
all the [ __ ] traitors out there
but here in march 2022 hey we're got not
quite a year later it quietly resumes
donating to these members so toyota is
in the news today
for donating
to the traders of our country and the
people who wanted to break their oath
like marjorie taylor green that purger
that we seen on friday perjuring herself
well and she was trying to protect her
ass when you say [ __ ] like i don't
recall when they're asking specific
questions about crimes you committed a
crime probably
you're just trying not to incriminate
yourself
[ __ ] idiot
oh here's a good tweet i found bridget
gabriel it's dumb [ __ ] she tweets the
founding fathers got it right the first
time i said the part about owning humans
must be your fave
bridge
you're a dumb [ __ ] she really is this is
the stupid [ __ ] we have to deal with
this is the dumb crt narrative all
wrapped up in a bow when she's saying
the founding fathers got it right the
first time
that's what she's saying
um speaking of dumb [ __ ] not knowing
what capitalism is like the uh the great
uh troll we had on facebook here or
there is she's still in the is she's
still in the comments i think she left i
think we scared her off anyways scared
off the troll we pointed her out oh my
god her full name ended up on a show on
youtube that thousands tens of thousands
of people watch every single day ah she
can't have that that was really [ __ ]
dumb of you to post a comment that i
could pull up on the screen how she
didn't know i could do that what an
idiot
uh joe from jurors here um is is takes a
screenshot of lauren bobert lauren bro
but don't know what capitalism is either
she says for communism to exist
capitalism must be removed
along with everything it represents well
this is really [ __ ] dumb this this
statement here is really [ __ ] dumb
because she claims this state stupid
same dumb [ __ ] claims that
coming in china is communist
but what she doesn't know is they have
capitalism in china
so
communism to exist doesn't mean that
capitalism has to be removed there's
different forms of capitalism you stupid
shits
want a bunch of dumb dumbasses who would
to think that a person who stayed
married to a guy who was showing his
wiener to a bunch of teenagers in the
bowling alley wasn't worth a [ __ ] and
didn't have brains to
to save a goose when you see the radical
left here's what lauren bobert says when
you see the radical left tearing down
every bit of amer the american
foundation it fits right into their plan
you are really dumb
joe points it out here removing
capitalism y'all trying to shut down
disney world you [ __ ] like there's
no there's no other form of pure blooded
american capitalism than [ __ ] disney
world
disney world
jesus
they are a bunch of dumb [ __ ] thank
you joe for for your tweet
pointing that out that they don't know
what capitalism is
just like diana in the comments earlier
she had no clue she was calling me a
gabe socialist she had no clue that we
were actually talking about free market
free free market we were talking about
capitalism
no clue we were talking about capitalism
when we were talking about twitter and
elon musk like we were making the points
that cap up capitalism of how it's gonna
work you stupid [ __ ]
uh catherine uh you're pointing out the
uh the trump uh ten thousand dollars a
day story we're gonna get to that we're
uh
21 minute 22 minutes into the second
hour here we're gonna get to that story
i promise now forrest from facebook says
jojo from jeers is tops
absolutely i want to bring some of your
guys comments in here
um
[Music]
do you guys have anything to say about
toyota
um
cause toyota toyota said um
again the toyota story is they did pull
donations from the insurrectionists but
now
but now
they want to give them money um did you
guys see on youtube you need to go
subscribe to our youtube channel um
here's the highlights
if you guys go to the youtube channel
and see the thumbnail with the marjory
taylor green highlights
last friday we streamed for eight hours
literally it was eight hours and 31
seconds i was just 31 seconds over eight
hours
we streamed the marjorie taylor green
insurrection hearing
all goddamn day
but what i did so you don't have to
watch the whole eight hours i cut out
all the commentary
and the mark the majority of marjorie
taylor green's testimony i tried to cut
out all the breaks and that sort of
thing but i still tried to give you the
full version of her testimony
and then our commentary specifically
karen agnipolo kfa from legal af she
came on and helped us with legal
commentary that that day which was very
helpful because she described a lot of
things that you may or may not know
about a courtroom and what was happening
while it was happening which is very
important
so go over to the youtube channel don't
forget to subscribe to the youtube
channel now that's very important that
way you can go catch that highlight
video
you can watch it on on a faster speed so
you can watch it through but i wanted to
make
a shorter version of friday number one
so we could put it on the podcast
directories because you can go download
that same
episode
uh on apple spotify google any of your
most popular directories wherever you
get your podcast you can go download
this highlight episode
on the podcast directories
so you can hear our commentary and you
can hear marjory taylor green's
testimony her lying ass
having dementia i don't recall i don't
recall i don't recall having an
instructor i don't recall i don't recall
being a traitor i don't recall i don't
recall i don't recall she kept doing
this [ __ ] so go check it out on the um
the podcast directories or on
the youtube channel also because we had
a little because it was friday the bone
end of the week we did put bone in the
week on the youtube channel but i also
took bonehead of the week out of the
three and a half hours so if you want to
listen the bonehead of the week
if you're a bonenette of the week fan
we posted it separately on
the podcast directories so again go go
over to your podcast directories
and download bone of the week i think
we're going to do that every week from
now on we'll we'll pull out bonehead
because you guys love the boneheaded
leak so we'll pull out the bone end of
the week
and then we'll just post just the bone
in the week up on the directories for
you guys to go listen to it
you guys love the bone end of the week i
we i really like the bonehead that we do
it's fun it's fun for you guys to vote
and then we when we go through your vote
because you guys get to decide who the
[ __ ] the bonehead is sometimes it's very
clear sometimes it's really close
because a lot of these boneheads are the
boneheadedness is pretty damn close to
each other
but go check that out and go download on
the directory so i think we'll continue
to do and if anyone doesn't know what
bonehead of the week is
it bone end of the week is where we uh
actually uh we send out a tweet
so go follow us at tony michael's pod we
send out a tweet a poll every single
week on thursdays and you guys get the
vote for bonehead of the week and then
on friday in the second hour we actually
go through your vote
you decide to the bone hand of the week
is we break it down for you me and gabe
sanchez my co-host and executive
producer
on this in the second hour of the show
every single friday
so go go go follow at tonymichaelspod on
twitter and you'll be able to vote
you'll be able to vote for the bonehead
of the week all right let's go to the
tweet tweets and trendy trends let's see
this um
this story uh reinstate trump is is
trending of course that has to do with
elon musk i think we beat that to death
uh already today free speech true true
social that's the same [ __ ]
now where is this donald trump story
martial law
is trending what the [ __ ] you guys know
on friday i talked about martial law a
lot
in my commentary
you guys know that if you watched it and
if you guys go watch you'll see me talk
about martial law a lot especially at
the end after marjory taylor green's
testimony um
let's see
uh marshall cohen here says whoa new
text obtained by cnn showing marjorie
taylor green told meadows ah [ __ ] gabe
gabe if you're listening there's new
meadows tweets from marjory taylor green
you better get your video cued up he's
gonna make a video i know it
gabe's probably already standing in
front of a camera with his pipe
text text messages from mark to mark
meadows
um
uh the the story says marjorie taylor
green told meadows that he should talk
to trump about the possibility of
invoking martial law she testified
friday in the note that she couldn't
remember she had invoked martial law
perjury
perjury purge
perjury
rest her lock her up lock her up lock
her up lock her up there you go there's
you a good chant i don't know i don't
know if that's happened before but i'd
like to get that chant going uh january
17th marjorie taylor green to mark
meadows in our private chat with only
members
several are saying the only way to save
our republic is for trump to call for
martial law there it is i don't know on
i don't know on those things i just
wanted to tell him they stole this
election we all know
they will destroy our country next
please tell them to de-classify as much
as possible so we can go after biden and
anyone else
she's calling for martial law for the
insurrection i'll tell you here in a
minute why i'll tell you here in a
minute why
margie taylor green's testimony here's
here's the um
here's the script you can go watch the
the uh
you can go watch the film though on our
youtube channel go subscribe to our
youtube channel just type in the tony
michaels podcast on youtube and you have
the highlights right there and we played
almost the entire testimony of marjorie
taylor green uh the challenger's lawyer
andrew silly says
miss green did you advocate to president
trump to impose martial law as a way to
remain in power
rep green i don't recall
the lawyer says so you're not denying it
you did it you just don't remember she
said i don't remember yep okay sure
thing
okay so i talked about martial law a lot
on friday
here's the reason why you want to hear
the reason why
and then we'll get to the trump story
because we're 29 minutes into the hour
listen
the thing about martial law
and you can draw lines from donald trump
and and john eastman
to martial law doing martial law with
the eastman memo
the oath keepers founder stuart rhodes
and the proud boys were in coordination
with roger stone got it i've said this
over and over and over again the proud
boys were supposed to be the personal
protection of roger stone
after the meeting with stuart rhodes and
enrique tario which enrique tario was
the leader of the proud boys who was not
supposed to be in washington dc
when he met met on january 5th in a
parking garage with stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers
who was in charge of the qrf the weapons
the armed weapons that were stored
across the potomac in a hotel room
that's right they had weapons they had a
stash of weapons they had to store it in
virginia across the potomac because it
was only legal to have those weapons
there it was not legal to have those
westmans in washington dc unless
martial law was declared
you don't think marjorie taylor greene
was in communication with the proud boys
and the oath keepers
you don't think you don't think that the
two people who have pled guilty the one
proud boy who has pled guilty to
obstructing an official proceeding and
the and the oath keeper
who has pled guilty to conspiracy to
commit sedition
you don't think you don't think that
marjorie taylor greene roger stone and
the fact that judge carter a federal
judge in the state of california has
deemed that the emails that were
exchanged between john eastman and
donald trump was not covered by a
turning client privilege because they
clearly committed crimes that would fall
under the the the charge of conspiracy
to obstruct a official proceeding which
we see a proud boy who was supposed to
be protecting
roger stone during january 5th they
switched that fact that the oath keepers
would protect him so there was an oath
keeper a lieutenant of stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keeper who had the
go-ahead who had the orders for the qrf
the weapons stored across the potomac
for anyone out there to not say that
this was an armed insurrection is a
[ __ ]
bonehead they were armed they were ready
they were waiting for orders of martial
law and here we have here we have
marjorie taylor green
calling on mark meadows who's standing
next to the president of the united
states
calling on him to call for martial law
so that way
so that way they can overturn the
election
and they can make sure that that joe
biden is not peacefully transferred
power just like she said at the hearing
martial law was always on their mind
the entire time
before
during and after january 6
it's clear to see what their motives
were
and i can't wait to see the text
messages that were sent before january
17th
um here is uh brian um
brian tyler cohen has the video here's
the short clip to 10 seconds did you
advocate to president trump to impose
martial law as a way to remain in power
i don't recall
so you're not denying you did it you
just don't remember i don't remember
there you go
there you go there's the actual clip
there's the clip thank you brian for
posting that
all right let's see if we can find this
that we're 33 minutes into the second
hour here on the tony michaels podcast
coming to you every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch don't forget to go to subscribe
to our youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast
we're also broadcasting live from midas
touch facebook page
if you're out there on the books of face
we are broadcasting live to you
straight to your
straight to your facebook news feed or
whatever the hell it's called whatever
it's called over there on facebook i
don't know and i don't get on face i'm
on facebook every single day but i don't
actually get on facebook that much hello
let's see let's go back to the trendy
trends and the tweety tweets uh so
martial law is trending uh true social
of course trending toyota we kind of
went through that
up the johnny depp
amber heard story is still trending are
you on
team amber team johnny i was asked this
that this weekend
let's see what else we got um
where's this uh here we go then
nyag here's the story folks
here's the story uh let's see tristan
has it here breaking trump held in
contempt by new york judge granting new
york attorneys general motion to enforce
investigatory subpoena for production of
documents and witnesses trump must pay
ten thousand dollars per day until he
complies he better start grifting hey
trump supporters you better start
[ __ ] feeding this guy money he's
going to run out quick that broke
[ __ ] can't afford 10 days he
can't even afford to keep his plane in
the air
this guy can't even afford to keep his
broke ass plane in here he can't afford
ten thousand dollars a day
god damn you but you better go you
better go you better go
give to the trump fund that's why i
played the trump fund commercial earlier
is you better you better go give money
to the trump fund he's gonna need it
he's gonna have to spend ten thousand
dollars a day
he can't even keep his broke ass [ __ ]
airplane in the air
he broke [ __ ] he's a broke
[ __ ] that's why he has to have
these nazi rallies like he did this
weekend
there's the story we'll see how it's
enforced i'm not sure how it will be
enforced
and if it or if it will be i'm not sure
how they'll charge him i i doubt he pays
the bill
okay um speaking of uh let's go back to
the timeline because i want to show you
a [ __ ] video speaking of the trump
rally
this is a [ __ ] crazy ass video you
gotta see this [ __ ]
i said holy actual [ __ ] this is less
than a minute we're gonna watch it here
let me make it bigger
these are the people that you want in
charge of your children's education
these are the people that you want in
charge of your gas prices these are the
people you want in charge of making sure
your grocery store and your supply
chains are up and running listen to this
[ __ ] nut bag
okay first of all y'all are
so cute i love the outfits yeah she
loves the outfits and she loves the
creepy ass [ __ ] trump heads
what this is on rsb and this is some
kind of [ __ ] fascist
rag
some kind of fascist traitor tv
but they love her outfits but look at
this lady right here in the middle she's
got princess diana is the the one that's
probably the most familiar there and
that you can see right now but she's got
a trump
medal on or something like that and
they're carrying creepy ass trump faces
this is [ __ ] weird-ass cult-ass [ __ ]
what listen to what this
nin kapoop nazi says
i would like detailed explanations on
every single shirt oh well
breaking news breaking news from the
trump rally we're gonna get an
exclamation of a t-shirt holy how is
this [ __ ] how is this [ __ ] news
how is this [ __ ] news that you're
gonna you're gonna are you [ __ ] me
that you're gonna evaluate all the
t-shirts in line and get an explanation
of t-shirts and that's supposed to be
[ __ ] riveting get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] listen to what these
crazy wackadoos say
looney tunes type [ __ ] ready set go
right so
living
living and we know living
she's saying
jackie kennedy and princess diana are
living that they're alive
what the [ __ ]
what in the [ __ ] is wrong with these
people well listen listen to what she
says
even after i mean like like you're like
oh okay
she's a nut bag it goes it i mean it
gets nuttier than squirrel turds even
after that
rule in the world
and you don't take down evil by being
quiet or silent right um when's the last
time you heard anything from princess
diana when is the last [ __ ] time she
said something
being silent she's [ __ ] dead dummy
she's taking a dirt nap
she hasn't been alive for
forever
what the [ __ ] are you people talking
about
she's silent because she's dead oh my
god so people need to understand who
they are do they look like them today no
yeah i had plastic surgery
princess diana is still alive absolutely
100
and this reporter is like oh that's
crazy ass [ __ ] but listen to what she
does listen to how she capitulates to
this dumb [ __ ]
do you
i didn't but maybe maybe you have
something to that you know that i don't
know oh my god sh remember diana in the
comments earlier is diana still here i
hope diana's still listening remember
diana in the [ __ ] comments she's the
gal in the [ __ ] this might be diana hell
i don't know maybe diane is from ohio
[ __ ] i don't know i have no idea maybe
this is diana in the goddamn pink
t-shirt it could be [ __ ]
i don't know how am i supposed to know
holy [ __ ]
absolutely absolutely crazy ass [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ]
what in the [ __ ] are they talking about
and then the reporter's like well maybe
you know something i don't maybe you
read something on facebook
is there a meme on facebook
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] well you know god speaks
to us right
there's ways that we can figure these
things out so people start learning yeah
there's a way you can figure it out
pluck your head out of your [ __ ] ass
that's how you figure [ __ ] out you pluck
pluck your head
out of your ass
dig the [ __ ] out of your [ __ ] ears
and and listen to some real goddamn
facts
that's that's how you do it for crying
out [ __ ] loud jesus [ __ ] christ
god damn i i can't even hardly finish
this it's only a minute and here we are
geez abc one two three which michael
jackson talked about how many years ago
right what you thought it wasn't gonna
get crazier you thought oh tony it's
done she said she's nuttier than a
squirrel turd there's no way it can get
crazier than that here she's talking
about michael jackson abc123 what the
hell does that have to do with anything
well she's gonna tell you keep me sung
about so when people start understanding
gematria they start understanding the
numbers gematria what the f oh my god is
this the whole one equals a one oh my
god
this code word [ __ ]
these people really have [ __ ] they
flew over the cuckoo's nest
they're out to lunch
jesus
whoosh
several beers shy of a six pack
or all foam no beer holy [ __ ]
we need mental health in this country
and we need it fast like we need
institution mental institutions
and we need them fast and we need good
ones
help fast hurry
this lady is completely [ __ ]
this this person is a functioning person
out in society and some people were
saying oh she votes like that was the
most popular comment
about how this person this person
probably doesn't know where to vote
that's that's the [ __ ] craziest part
about all this is this [ __ ] right here
on the screen she probably doesn't vote
she probably doesn't even know where to
vote she's probably never voted in her
entire life
i'm dead serious i think the biggest
fraud that's ever been wrought on the
american people is somehow donald
trump's support is steady and he has a
huge swath of support in this country
and they [ __ ] love him
no
no they love republicans being in power
so they can discriminate against the
people that they want republicans to
discriminate against that's what they
love about trump they don't give a [ __ ]
about him this lady's a nut bag she
cares a shitload about trump but she
probably doesn't vote
she probably doesn't she probably
couldn't find the [ __ ] voting booth
even if you gave her a map
how could she [ __ ]
i'm calling this lady diana i don't care
what you say
a equals one b equals two c equals three
they understand how words work sentence
oh they understand how words work in
sentences holy [ __ ]
this is what we're dealing with
okay let's go back to the trendy trends
and tweety tweets we're 42 minutes into
the hour
let's see rick perry is now trending
um he is denying speaking of text
messages to mark meadows
it appears
uh molly here from
she's she's with the washington post
she says incredible rick perry denied
sending text messages to mark meadows
with suggest suggestions about
overturning the election results
expect that he signed one of his text
messages rick perry
with his
with his phone number
oh
my god
mark meadows is in a heap of [ __ ] here
folks he is in a heap
of [ __ ] [ __ ]
it is um
oh boy it's getting thicker and thicker
with these text messages it is clear why
members of congress like josh hawley
mike lee and
and ted cruz were absolutely terrified
that the department of justice would get
their hands
on metadata including text messages to
mark meadows it is very clear now why
they were terrified of that
see we had a bunch of comments coming in
oh uh caitlin's saying that uh jason
miller's have have come out too there
must have been a huge data dump
and i i don't pun intended a big huge
trump data dump mark meadows trump data
dump
um on text messages today
um
holy [ __ ]
uh franklin graham is trending too i
want to see what uh franklin graham is
up to not but let's see why this [ __ ]
box is trending i'm sure it's because he
is a shitbox
um evangelist reverend franklin graham
applauds for to florida governor ron
desantis
of course he does to move to repeal
disney's special tax exemption status
and tax floridians and speaks out
against the entertainment company's
moral failure
so because disney's standing up for
equality inequity for human beings
they're seeing the humanity in humans
franklin graham is pissed off
and sees the moral fa what in the
god it just
uh
everyone stands around wondering why
people are
in droves running away from the american
christian church
there's no better explanation than it
right here
that franklin graham
is applauding
that ron desantis is trying to tax
floridians
because he's a bigot and he hates gay
people lgbtq people trans people
and children and he wants to sexualize
your children
and their gender in a classroom and
franklin graham is applauding that you
are a special kind of stupid and a
special kind of piece of [ __ ] franklin
graham
you truly are
uh
is there video footage of this or is he
just write it somewhere
i think he just wrote it somewhere and a
piece of [ __ ]
yeah he just wrote it there's no [ __ ]
video footage
he only does video footage from russia
when he's over there vid visiting
his his bladdy daddy that's right
franklin graham is in cahoots
vladimir putin let's see what else do we
have here oh steve martin
uh mj thank you for the super chat for
the 2
319 mark meadows text messages released
today oh so there is a huge dump
there's a huge dump
more gqp crime again keep ranting tony
oh i'm not gonna stop as long as this
[ __ ] microphone's on we're gonna yell
and scream into it
i'm gonna cuss yell and scream i don't
give a [ __ ]
every day every week
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11th century you can
come here and watch me yell and scream
and do a microphone and rant into a
microphone for two straight hours every
single weekday on youtube twitter twitch
even if elon musk buys twitter i'm gonna
stay on twitter just like i stayed on
spotify
when all the woke lefties whatever they
call them wanted to boycott spotify i
stayed [ __ ] them i stayed
i stayed and now we're on the midas
touch facebook page you can catch us
there every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific
crystal says
i love these meadows text dumps days
yeah
that's the kind of dump that crystal's
in for
thank you for joining us here crystal
from facebook crystal's here almost
every single day
um mj gives hearts thank you mj thank
you very much thank you very much
let's see meat head is trending why is
media trending is it because uh
mark meadows
text dump
or is it because donald trump's gonna
get fined ten thousand dollars a day i
don't know i'm just i'm just throwing
out ideas here oh it's rob reiner meat
head from that right wing has meathead
trending because rob reiner
his character he's y'all meted they're
[ __ ] dumb
they're trying to distract that donald
trump is broke and he can't afford ten
thousand dollars a day let's go read
some jokes
we gotta have some good jokes let's see
who's got some good jokes mail have you
have you tweeted about um
trump's ten thousand dollars yet the new
york ag
someone's gotta have some good jokes
here i'm gonna go write some
some jokes
dude we got a bunch of news i to read
some funny [ __ ]
i don't want to read the news i know the
news he's broke and he can't afford ten
thousand dollars a day that's what the
news is
the news is this [ __ ] is broke
as a joke
he couldn't for ten he can't even afford
to keep his plane in the air
you can't convince me you cannot
convince me that this son of a [ __ ]
has ten thousand dollars a day give me a
[ __ ] break
someone says sent me caitlyn says she
sent me funny [ __ ] let's see
oh
is this it oh yeah okay let's see here's
george conway's tweet
george conway's tree let's pull this up
let's see what this has to say
george conway says yes
we have the gazpacho police round up
all the people who can't spell and
detain them in primary school um i don't
know i guess i guess he's misspelling in
text messages
[Laughter]
this has to do with the martial law text
message
and
i don't know is that what you're one
you're talking about or is there another
one
oh here's a jason miller this must be
jason miller tweets
let's go to the jason miller tweets here
let's see what's on the jason miller
tweets
there we go jason miller says wonder if
the people of getter
are aware that jason miller in dc was
privately debunking all the voter fraud
conspiracies
okay so here's some here's what's this
from what's he pulling this from
i don't know this must be jason miller's
words says a week later miller wrote to
meadows again this time saying that
campaign research did not find any
evidence of the conspiracy involving and
popping syrups ah god i get that a lot
ah you're paid by george soros
the democratic donor miller also said he
was concerned about sharing the finding
findings with trump
so jason miller knew that it was all
[ __ ] and he didn't want to tell
trump that it was [ __ ]
i guess this is a quote from the
from the text messages lights there
re-functionally functionally pro
functionality problems not much there on
den soros conspiracy connections so he's
debunking that in the text we'll refer
to you on whether or not to share full
report with potus oh we better not tell
him he'll be pissed that it's un that
what he wants to be true is untrue which
is most of the time
uh potus here's the quote potus is
clearly hyped up on them
in other words he's getting high on
these conspiracy theories not just from
his tweets but he also called me and
justin separately last night to complain
jm
jason miller
let's see this is the guy runs this is a
guy who doesn't have a chin he's a
chinless [ __ ] you know this is
the chin this [ __ ] that tries to
run getter you know they went and bought
cheap ass pickup trucks to go try to get
people they were buying people trucks to
create accounts on getter that's how
[ __ ] desperate they were
to get people to create create accounts
on getter
they were [ __ ] buying people pickup
trucks i'm not [ __ ] you go back and
look
just type in jason miller pickup trucks
or jason miller getter trucks or
whatever you want to do
you'll go find it
maybe we'll do that here and we are 52
minutes into the second hour we're
closing we're closing in on the end
folks
but that's okay
we'll do some more surfing here
and then we'll start tomorrow noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific because
it's every single weekday monday through
friday for two hours every day youtube
twitter twitch and now the midas touch
facebook page
so let's read this little quote here
from the story that is the dump of
meadows text messages on november 6th
miller which is just days after the
election miller
trump's campaign spokesman tested text a
group so this is a group text with
ivanka trump kushner hicks
stefan scavino and meadows so this is a
group chat
suggesting that the numbers in
philadelphia didn't back up the claims
about the alleged election fraud there
no [ __ ] sherlock the other key data
point in 2016 potus received 15.5
percent of the vote in philadelphia
county today is currently at 18.3
so he increased from his performance in
2016.
in 2016
philadelphia county made up 11.3 percent
of the total vote in the state
as it currently stands philadelphia
county only makes up 10.2
of the statewide vote tally so potus
performing better in a small share
rick santorum was just making this point
on cnn cuts hard against the urban vote
stealing narrative
miller rope
so jason miller
was continuing
his debunking of the [ __ ] election
fraud stuff the big lie even jason
miller is like yeah [ __ ] that big lie
[ __ ] you can't even you can't even hang
your hat on a simple fact
retro
thank you tim miller for the tweet i
don't think tim is uh related to jason
in any way
it just so happens that they share the
last common name of miller
thank you for the tweet
let's go back to the tweety tweets and
trending trends here now we're 54
minutes in the hour again about five
minutes left
let's see if anything new is a trending
canada is now trending uh let's see what
the hell is canada trending for oh my
god the world's coming to [ __ ]
now people in canada are acting like
they're mad they want uh freedom that
the united states has that they don't
what are you talking about
what are you talking about
this is nonsense
okay we're going to go back i'm not
going to get into that that rabbit hole
anything else
thank you for joining us here on this
monday
morning as you do every single monday
morning don't forget don't forget to
like and share
this this broadcast
um whether you're on
facebook or
or twitter
or twitch or youtube
make sure you're you're sharing and
liking the podcast commenting down below
even if even if the trolls are here it's
okay
it's okay oh one piece of news i do want
to talk about is the russia russia thing
real quick real quick we're 55 minutes
into the hour
hang with me here um
secretary blinken
and secretary austin
went to ukraine and met with president
zielinski in kiev um this is significant
this shows that the united states is
standing with ukraine not just with uh
president biden
giving aid
and and weapons but also
making sure that we can aid and having
ukrainian citizens come here
um as refugees for i think up to two
years is the program they're talking
about hundreds of thousands of
ukrainians coming to our country
to contribute to our economy and
possibly going back to their home once
the war is over
um
so so that signal of the physical
presence of the united states to
diplomatic arm
meeting with the president of ukraine is
a strong signal to the world that the
united states joe biden the the american
people and the american government
are standing with ukraine it's very
significant um and apparently this news
came this morning
after the fact and there's some video
out there but it's very significant in
the war
um where russia is the aggressor and
vladimir putin that murders dictator
is committing war crimes in the
sovereign country and sovereign nation
the democracy that is ukraine the
imperfect democracy but democracy still
and i believe that democracy won
they won this weekend with this act and
also the act of the france
the french election and the people of
france
rejecting a fascist a putin
paid fascist that is le pen
uh even mcchrome who is very unpopular
in france with some of his policies and
some of the ways that he's handled
government and the covid crisis in
france he still was elected
because anything is better than a
putin-backed fascist like we had in this
country
the world learned its lesson when donald
trump was elected to the president the
office of the presidency in our country
a putin back putin paid for fascist it
is donald trump the world learned its
lesson
and i believe france spoke loud and
clear
this weekend and they said
no to fascism yes to democracy even as
imperfect as democracy may be
we want democracy not fascism we do not
want authoritarianism we do not we
absolutely do not want a putin paid
president
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
we are not going to have that garbage
here in this country that's what france
said we said that in the 2020 election
i don't believe 81 million people voted
for joe biden
there is a shitload of that number of 81
million people that voted against donald
trump and voted against fascism they
voted against
trumpism which is fascism in a manga hat
in this country they voted against a
putin paid president
and the same thing that the french
people did this over the weekend to make
sure that macron stayed
present in a pro-democracy fashion even
though they're not exactly keen on
mcchrome and his policies
they still made sure that democracy won
that's the important part
and i believe we can do the same thing
here in this country in the 2022
midterms we just got to keep yelling and
screaming that's why i'm going to keep
yelling and screaming in this microphone
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central 9 pacific
on youtube twitter
twitch now coming to you from the midas
touch facebook page every single weekday
monday through friday
and it's been a great monday hanging out
with you guys going over the news
stories
and until tomorrow
when we stream again and we go live and
we yell and scream to make sure to save
our democracy not just here but around
the world
until then surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking